Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de Franz 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
en esta edición de reporteros los
llevaremos a Islandia un país conocido
por sus glaciares y sus impresionantes
vistas de la Aurora boreal pero no son
solo sus paisajes lo que distingue a la
isla su política también la hace única
desde hace más de una década Islandia
encabeza el informe del foro económico
mundial sobre igualdad de género una
batalla ganada a pulso en la lucha por
los derechos de la mujer es la primera
nación del mundo en haber adoptado una
ley que obliga a pagar el mismo sueldo
tanto a hombres como mujeres el 48% de
los diputados son mujeres lo que
convierte al parlamento islandés en el
más equilibrado de Europa en cuanto a
género
en el siguiente reporteros la periodista
melinahué analizas Islandia está a la
altura de su reputación como modelo de
igualdad de género veamos la historia
[Música]
en esta Isla donde solo viven 380.000
personas las mujeres obtuvieron el
derecho al voto en 1915 fue el primer
país en haber elegido democráticamente a
una jefa de estado hace 40 años
[Música]
existe una ley sobre igualdad salarial y
una licencia parental ejemplar
en 1975 una huelga feminista paralizó el
país
es una nación campeona de la paridad de
género
pero en la que nada se da por sentado
es Islandia realmente el paraíso de la
igualdad entre mujeres y hombres
[Música]
en Islandia la igualdad de género se
enseña desde el jardín infantil
[Aplausos]
en los años 80 Mark
inventó un método pionero en el mundo el
modelo
esta palabra significa romper los tabúes
la idea nació a raíz de algo que Mark
observó tras años de trabajo como
profesora de preescolar y primaria
[Música]
por alguna razón los niños ocupaban más
espacios de lo que se esperaba
mientras que las niñas se hacían a un
lado expresaban más dudas
y pensé que es lo que está pasando
entonces cae en cuenta de algo Dios mío
mis niñas no tienen nada de malo aunque
se aparten mis niños no tienen nada de
malo Aunque ocupen más lugar del que me
gustaría
es el marco lo que está mal
Mark creó entonces un nuevo tipo de
escuela en la que invita a los alumnos a
salir de ese famoso marco
aquí niños y niñas son separados durante
una parte del día todas las actividades
que generalmente le son asignadas a uno
u otro de los grupos se practican de
manera indiscriminada entonces jugar
fútbol no es solo algo de niños
Y cuidar de uno mismo y de los demás no
es una tarea reservada para las niñas
[Música]
es la directora de esta escuela una de
las 17 que están repartidas por todo el
territorio cuando vio que las niñas se
quedaban en un rincón del patio de
recreo mientras que los niños lo
ocupaban por completo decidió dividirlo
equitativamente en dos espacios
separados solo por un camino los niños
vinieron a hablarnos porque tenían la
impresión de que les habíamos quitado su
espacio
mientras que las niñas nos preguntaban
si podían ir a un sitio o a otro
pedían permiso para utilizar el espacio
que les habíamos dado
Entonces les enseñé a los niños a ser
más justos y a las niñas a usar el
espacio
aquí niños y niñas se vuelven a reunir
al final de la jornada no tienen ningún
problema para jugar juntos Aunque al
principio el método cheatly fue
cuestionado mal grid fue condecorada por
el gobierno islandés en 2007 por su
Innovación pedagógica y por los
resultados escolares obtenidos sin duda
somos las únicas escuelas y jardines
infantiles de Islandia en tener unos
estudios que respaldan nuestros métodos
nos hemos dado cuenta de que los niños
que vienen aquí cuando crecen tienen una
mentalidad más abierta frente a los
estereotipos de género nuestros alumnos
también son los mejores en todas las
asignaturas alumnos de mente más abierta
con menos ideas preconcebidas de género
y madres para quienes la maternidad ya
no supone un freno en su carrera
profesional después de Rey javic Nos
dirigimos a selfs a una hora de la
capital nos encontramos con una familia
que tiene cuatro hijos
estoy preparando unos súper panqueques
hechos en casa para los niños
apenas se den cuenta de lo que estoy
cocinando van a escuchar unos ruiditos
mientras David cocina astros divide su
tiempo entre la vida de familia la
gestión de un negocio en línea y el
compromiso político
una cotidianidad que comparte en las
redes sociales he estado embarazada casi
sin interrupción desde diciembre de 2017
esto nunca me ha impedido hacer las
cosas que me parecen importantes como
presentarme a las elecciones locales
desde que nació el último bebé astrucy
David se dividieron la licencia parental
Para que ella pudiera hacer campaña algo
que está lejos de ser un problema para
este papá que desea pasar más tiempo con
sus hijos Me encantaría ser amo de casa
el bebé tiene derecho a un año con sus
padres dividido en dos seis meses para
el padre seis meses para la madre
en 2021 la licencia parental pasó de 10
a 12 meses con seis semanas
transferibles a uno u otro de los padres
tengo algunos amigos que viven en
Estados Unidos y los individuos
puedo entender
pagan por quedarnos en casa
lo que recibimos está muy lejos de lo
que ganamos en realidad
en Islandia los subsidios corresponden
al 80% del salario promedio del
progenitor y pueden alcanzar un límite
de 4.200 euros al mes un escenario que
despertaría la envidia de muchos otros
europeos pero las conductas sociales han
evolucionado tan rápido que los
islandeses ahora exigen más flexibilidad
a sus gobernantes se necesitan más
opciones para los padres bien sea para
la guardería para el jardín infantil o
para quedarse en casa y recibir un pago
por eso es uno como madre o padre el que
debería poder decidir astros y su de
Centro derecha militan actualmente por
una licencia remunerada de tres años
un escenario en el que las mujeres
islandesas participan desde hace mucho
tiempo
el 24 de octubre de 1975 organizaron la
primera huelga feminista del país un
maremoto social
para obtener más derechos el 90% de las
mujeres dejó de trabajar tanto dentro
como fuera del hogar la consecuencia el
país entero se detuvo
tuna fue una de ellas
tenía entonces 23 años y participó en
una concentración de mujeres en el
Noroeste del país su recuerdo de esta
jornada histórica está intacto me
acuerdo muy bien de volver a casa
después de esa concentración y sentir un
olor a carne quemada en todas las calles
por qué porque los hombres estaban
tratando de hacer la cena esa huelga
inédita ocupó las primeras planas de los
periódicos internacionales y permitió
que varias leyes se aprobaran
rápidamente
el derecho a la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo que no existía hasta ese
momento
también centramos la atención sobre la
importancia del cuidado infantil
qué podían hacer las mujeres si tenía
que trabajar fuera de casa
necesitaban guarderías después de la
huelga está profesora de antropología
cofundó la lista de las mujeres el
primer partido feminista islandés
en 1983 fue elegida diputada en el
parlamento y atrajo la mirada del mundo
entero
nos eligieron a tres en el parlamento
Christine hurón y yo Este es un
periódico de Dinamarca donde dice las
mujeres islandesas han logrado un
milagro
en ninguna otra parte del mundo había
triunfado un partido fundado sobre las
ideas feministas
hubo algunas tentativas pero fracasaron
sólo funcionó en Islandia
Explica el triunfo por la historia del
país durante 150 años las mujeres se
ocuparon de la casa mientras sus maridos
se iban al mar para pescar según ella
también tiene que ver con la poca
cantidad de habitantes que hay en la
isla es muy probable tener algún
familiar ir a la escuela con alguien o
ser amigo de una persona que hace parte
de un movimiento feminista y eso hace
que las personas sean más susceptibles a
esas ideas
el último avance importante fue en 2018
con una ley que impuso la igualdad
salarial desde entonces ya no le
corresponde a las trabajadoras demostrar
que son discriminadas sino a los
empleadores probar que no las
discriminan un modelo pionero que le ha
permitido a Islandia encabezar desde
hace 12 años el informe mundial sobre
paridad de género Pero según la
profesora Esto no es motivo de
celebración ser los primeros en esa
clasificación no quiere decir que
estemos en un nivel alto porque el resto
de los países están muy mal es verdad
hemos logrado mucho pero una cosa es
tener una legislación en vigor y otra
que sea respetada
todavía queda mucho pero creo que vamos
en la dirección correcta para que en el
futuro potencialmente podamos alcanzar
la igualdad de género
Porque nada suele ser perfecto
Incluso en Islandia en el país 22% de
las mujeres son o han sido Víctimas de
violencia doméstica
a veces me preguntan Pero cómo puede ser
que en un paraíso de la igualdad como
Islandia Todavía existe la violencia de
género
y la respuesta más factible es que no es
un paraíso de la igualdad de género
dirige Un refugio para las mujeres que
huyen de las violencias fundado en 1982
es de los más antiguos de Europa
pienso que tenemos buenas leyes en lo
que respecta las órdenes de alejamiento
funcionan de manera muy sencilla pero no
se aplican
creo que ese es el mayor problema en
Islandia
Hola Sonia Cómo estás Hey Qué bueno
volver a verte cuánto tiempo sí desde
septiembre Sonya estuvo en el refugio
con sus dos hijos actualmente la
sobrevivientes pueden quedarse Hasta por
un año quieres que te muestre los
apartamentos vamos
el alquiler de estos apartamentos es dos
veces inferior a los precios del mercado
en esa época Sonya pudo quedarse
gratuitamente en el refugio pero su
estadía solo fue de unas cuantas semanas
aún así ese paréntesis lo cambió todo
para ella realmente me salvó la vida
permite cortar el vínculo con el agresor
su ex esposo le infringió violencias
físicas y psicológicas durante 18 años
unos abusos que según son ya fueron
tratados con demasiada ligereza por la
justicia
mi ex esposo fue condenado a nueve meses
de prisión pero salió al cabo de tres
ocasiones
de la manera como mi ex esposo me
agredió en mi casa
probablemente habría sido condenado por
intento de homicidio o algún motivo
similar porque me golpeó con demasiada
violencia no solo con sus manos y pies y
y también me golpeó con una botella de
vidrio y amenazó con lanzarme por el
balcón
antes de echarme del apartamento
entonces para mí eso es un intento de
homicidio nada más
a pesar de todos son ya se siente
afortunada por haber podido beneficiarse
de una legislación pionera please ahora
la policía puede entrar al domicilio y
tienen una ventana de 24 horas para
separar a la pareja y orientar a la
víctima
en las 24 horas posteriores a una
llamada investigadores con formación en
violencia de género y también
trabajadores sociales o incluso agentes
de protección infantil deben acudir al
domicilio el objetivo es impedir que el
agresor vuelva a atraer a la víctima y
descartar por completo la posibilidad de
que la agresión se repita
inicialmente esta medida fue introducida
a nivel local por una antigua abogada
que se incorporó a las fuerzas del orden
hace dos años
Fue nombrada jefa de la Policía Nacional
recibimos siete reportes Al Día de
violaciones o violencia
domésticas es un aumento del 19% tan
solo los tres primeros meses del año
unas cifras preocupantes que según ella
paradójicamente se explican por el éxito
que han tenido las campañas de
sensibilización desde hace 10 años
ahora lucha para que todas las denuncias
lleven a un juicio y que las mujeres
estén acompañadas durante todo el
proceso por una persona dedicada a su
caso no hay que llamar a una oficina que
tratará de encontrar el informe o ir de
un lado a otro para obtener información
simplemente Tratamos de hacer las cosas
de manera distinta escuchando a nuestras
clientes escuchando a las personas a las
que debemos servir Y si las escuchamos
podemos mejorar las cosas en 2022 se
aprobó una ley que facilita el divorcio
las mujeres Víctimas de violencia
infligidas por su pareja Aunque Islandia
sea un modelo a seguir este pequeño país
todavía sigue en busca de la perfección
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
Recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]